BOOK TITLED "CONFIDENCE MAN, THE
MAKING OF DONALD TRUMP AND THE
BREAKING OF AMERICA."
DAVID GERGEN.
SO, PAUL, OBVIOUSLY THIS IS A
BIG WIN FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE.
DOES IT SURPRISE YOU WHAT
HAPPENS NEXT NOW THAT THEY CAN
CONTINUE USING THESE CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS?
>> IT REALLY DOESN'T SURPRISE ME
BECAUSE THIS RULING BY JUDGE
CANON THAT THE DOJ COULDN'T
INVESTIGATE WHAT WAS GOING ON
WITH THESE CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS
WAS REALLY KIND OF SHOCKING.
I MEAN SOURCES AND METHODS,
SPIES THAT WE HAVE IN OTHER
COUNTRIES.
WHO KNOWS WHAT ARE AFFECTED BY
THESE RECORDS.
AND TO SAY THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE COULDN'T LOOK AT THEM
WAS REALLY A SURPRISING RULING.
SO I THINK THE APPELLATE COURT
DECIDED THAT THIS WAS THE RIGHT
WAY TO GO WITH IT, AND THEY LEFT
THE REST PRETTY MUCH ALONE.
>> THE THREE-JUDGE PANEL OF THE
11th CIRCUIT ALSO REALLY LAM
BASTED THE PRIOR JUDGE, JUDGE
CANON.
I WANT TO READ WHAT THEY SAID.
THEY SAID THE DISTRICT COURT
ABUSED ITS DISCRETION -- EXPLAIN
WHAT THAT MEANS.
>> IT'S VERY UNUSUAL TO GET A
REBUKE LIKE THAT.
THE REFERRED REFERENCE TO EQUITY
HAS TO DO WHAT LAWYERS CALL IT
INJUNCTIVE RELIEF.
WHERE A JUDGE IS RULING THAT ONE
SIDE HAS TO GO TO JAIL BUT YOU
HAVE TO DO THINGS AFFIRMATIVELY,
AND IN THIS CASE NOT LOOK AT
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS WHEN THE
U.S. GOVERNMENT HAS EVERY RIGHT
TO LOOK AT ITS OWN CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS.
TRUMP DERIVED NO RIGHT TO DO
THAT JUST BECAUSE HE TOOK THEM
TO MAR-A-LAGO.
AND OF COURSE HIS ATTORNEYS
NEVER EVEN POSITED THE ARGUMENT
WITH EVIDENCE THAT HE HAD
DECLASSIFIED THOSE DOCUMENTS.
SO I THINK THE APPELLATE COURT
WAS REALLY DISTURBED BY AN
EGREGIOUS OVERREACH BY THE
DISTRICT JUDGE HERE AND SORT OF
SLAPPED BACK THAT DECISION AND
SAID, NO, DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
CAN HAVE THE RECORDS.
>> MAGGIE, THE FORMER PRESIDENT
RECEIVED A STRING OF FAVORABLE
DECISIONS RELATED TO THE SEARCH
OF MAR-A-LAGO FROM THAT DISTRICT
JUDGE.
DO YOU EXPECT HE'S GOING TO TRY
TO APPEAL THIS TO THE SUPREME
COURT?
OR I MEAN THERE'S ALSO
QUESTIONS, I GUESS, ABOUT HIS
LEGAL REPRESENTATION BECAUSE
IT'S BEEN CRITICIZED WIDELY EVEN
BY OTHER JUSTICES.
>> WE DON'T KNOW, ANDERSON, WHAT
THEIR RESPONSE IS GOING TO BE,
BUT CERTAINLY THE FORMER
PRESIDENT'S STRATEGY IN MOST OF
THESE LITIGATIONS HAS BEEN TO
TRY TO DRAG IT.
SO I ANTICIPATE THERE'S A STRONG
POSSIBILITY THEY'LL TRY TO
APPEAL TO A HIGHER COURT AND SEE
HOW FAR THIS GOES.
YOU KNOW, THIS HASN'T BEEN A
GREAT LEGAL WEEK FOR THEM.
I KNOW SOME PEOPLE AROUND THE
FORMER PRESIDENT YESTERDAY WERE
INSISTING THE SPECIAL MASTER
HEARING YESTERDAY WAS NOT THAT
BAD AND THAT THE SPECIAL MASTER
JUDGE RAY DEARIE DID NOT SOUND
THAT SKEPTICAL.
HE DID SOUND SKEPTICAL.
BUT THIS DECISION BY THIS
CIRCUIT, WHICH IS FILLED WITH A
LOT OF TRUMP APPOINTEES ON IT, I
THINK IS JUST ANOTHER SETBACK.
HOWEVER, I WILL JUST STRESS
TRUMP'S DESIRE IS ALWAYS TO DRAG
THESE THING SAID OUT.
AND DRAGGING IT OUT ISN'T
NECESSARILY SOMETHING HE'S GOING
TO BE UPSET ABOUT.
>> DAVID, THE 11th CIRCUIT ALSO
WROTE THE FORMER PRESIDENT
SUGGESTED HE DECLASSIFY THESE
DOCUMENTS BUT DIRECTLY STATED,
QUOTE, PLAINTIFF RESISTED
PROVIDING ANY EVIDENCE THAT HE
HAD DECLASSIFIED ANY OF THESE
DOCUMENTS, UNQUOTE.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THE FACT THE
FORMER PRESIDENT'S LEGAL TEAM
CONTINUES TO REFUSE TO PROVIDE
ANY EVIDENCE OF THAT CLAIM?
>> ANDERSON, I MAKE THIS WHAT IT
LOOKS LIKE, PRIMA FACIE, RIGHT?
GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY IF YOUR
LAWYERS CAN'T PRODUCE IT, IT
DIDN'T HAPPEN MOST LIKELY.
I BELIEVE THE JUDGE SAID YOU
CAN'T HAVE YOUR CAKE AND EAT IT,
TOO, IN THIS SITUATION.
YOU CAN'T CLAIM IT'S BEEN
DECLASSIFIED AND PROVIDE
EVIDENCE OF DECLASSIFICATION.
PRODUCE DOCUMENTS AND PRODUCE
THE RECEIPTS SHOWING IT WAS
ACTUALLY PUT IN THE -- YOU KNOW,
IN MOTION, AND THE CLASSIFYING
AUTHORITY WOULD DECLASSIFY IT
AND THERE'D BE ACTUAL DOCUMENTS
EVIDENCING THAT.
>> PAUL, DO YOU THINK THE
SUPREME COURT WOULD TAKE THE
CASE OF THE FORMER PRESIDENT
APPEALED IT TO THEM?
>> I DON'T THINK THAT THEY WILL,
BUT YOU HAVE A FORMER PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES HERE.
IT'S NOT AN ORDINARY CASE.
THEY COULD.
THERE'S ALSO ANOTHER OPTION WE
HAVEN'T DISCUSSED TONIGHT.
THEY COULD ASK FOR WHAT THEY
CALL AN EN BANC HEARING.
REMEMBER ONLY THREE JUDGES MADE
THIS DECISION.
YOU NORMALLY ONLY HAVE THE RIGHT
TO ASK THE ENTIRE CIRCUIT TO
HEAR THE ISSUE AND THEN YOU CAN
GO TO THE SUPREME COURT OR GO
DIRECTLY TO THE SUPREME COURT.
I THINK MAGGIE'S RIGHT TRUMP
DELAYS, DELAYS, DELAYS AND TRIES
TO OVERLITIGATE EVERYTHING, SO
HE MIGHT ASK FOR THE FULL ENBONK
HEARING BECAUSE THAT DELAYS
THINGS.
>> WHAT IMPACT, IF ANY, DO YOU
THINK THIS WOULD HAVE OR DO YOU
THINK IT WOULD HAVE ANY DECISION
ON WHETHER OR NOT HE WOULD RUN
AGAIN?
>> YOU MEAN THE DECISION IN NEW
YORK?
>> IN NEW YORK, YEAH.
>> LOOK, ANDERSON, I THINK YOU
CAN LOOK AT THIS IN TWO
DIFFERENT WAYS.
NUMBER ONE, A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO
HAVE TALKED TO THE FORMER
PRESIDENT SAY THEY DON'T THINK
HIS HEART SEEMS TO BE IN
POLITICS AND RUNNING AND
CAMPAIGNING THE WAY IT ONCE WAS.
THAT BEING SAID THE SECOND HE
SAYS HE'S NOT RUNNING HE LOSES A
LOT OF ATTENTION AND LOSES THE
ABILITY TO FUND RAISE
POLITICALLY, AND LOSES
POTENTIALLY IF HE WERE TO RUN
THE PROTECTIONS THAT THE OFFICE
AFFORDS A SITTING PRESIDENT IN
TERMS OF INVESTIGATIONS.
AND ALL OF THAT IS SOMETHING
THAT HE IS AWARE OF.
I THINK THAT, YOU KNOW, PEOPLE
I'VE SPOKEN TO CLOSE TO HIM WERE
VERY RELIEVED, STILL, AS THEY
HAVE BEEN OVER AND OVER THAT
THERE WAS NO CRIMINAL CHARGE
RELATED HERE.
THERE WAS A CRIMINAL REFERRAL
THAT WAS DISCUSSED, BUT THIS IS
A CIVIL ACTION.
AND I THINK YOU'RE GOING TO SEE
THEM FIGHT IT ON THE SAME
GROUNDS YOU HAVE SEEN THEM FIGHT
A LOT.
I WILL SAY THERE WERE A COUPLE
OF VERY NEW DETAILS RELATED TO
TRUMP'S FINANCIAL HABITS IN THIS
FILING, AND THERE WERE, YOU
KNOW -- THERE WERE CERTAINLY A
LOT OF DESCRIPTIONS THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL USED OF HIS PRACTICES.
SHE PUT TOGETHER A COMPREHENSIVE
FILING A LOT OF IT AND THIS IS
WHAT THE TRUMP FOLKS ARE
POINTING TO REPEATEDLY IS STUFF
THAT'S BEEN LARGELY KNOWN.
THE QUESTION IS WHETHER IT'S
GOING TO GET HEARD DIFFERENTLY
IN A COURT THIS TIME.
>> DAVID, DO YOU THINK THE
FORMER PRESIDENT WOULD BE LESS
LIKELY TO RUN AGAIN GIVEN ALL
THE NEWS TODAY AND JUST THE
SHEER VOLUME OF THE DRAMA
SURROUNDING IT?
>> RIGHT.
SO IF YOU STACK THEM UP THERE'S
POTENTIALLY FIVE CASES GOING ON
RIGHT NOW.
RIGHT, SO YOU HAVE THE CRIMINAL
SUIT BY NEW YORK STATE AGAINST
THE TRUMP ORGANIZATION, WHICH IS
ONGOING.
YOU HAVE THIS CIVIL SUIT NOW.
YOU HAVE THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY
IN FULTON COUNTY LOOKING AT THE
2020 ELECTION.
YOU HAVE THE JANUARY 6th
COMMITTEE AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE LOOKING AT JANUARY 6th.
THEN YOU HAVE THE MAR-A-LAGO
INCIDENT.
SO THERE ARE FIVE POTENTIAL
LAWSUITS GOING ON.
ANDERSON, IF THE PRESIDENT
DOESN'T RUN THEN HE CAN'T CLAIM
IT'S POLITICALLY MOTIVATED.
IF HE'S THE REPUBLICAN CANDIDATE
FOR THE PRESIDENCY HE CAN LOOK
AT THE NEW YORK ATTORNEY GENERAL
AND SAY, LOOK, AS MAGGIE SAID
THIS HAS ALL BEEN WELL-KNOWN AND
OUT IN PUBLIC FOR A LONG TIME
THAT THIS -- ALL THESE CLAIMS
AGAINST ME INFLATING MY VALUE OF
MY PROPERTIES AND NONE OF THE --
WE LOOK AT THE SUIT NONE OF THE
FINANCIALS WERE CERTIFIED.
THE ORGANIZATION DIDN'T
SIGN-OFF.
NONE OF THE ACCOUNTANTS SIGNED
OFF ON IT.
IF THE PRESIDENT'S NOT A
CANDIDATE THEN HE DOESN'T HAVE
THAT CARD TO PLAY, SO I WOULD
SAY IT MAKES HIM A LITTLE BIT
MORE LIKELY TO RUN.
>> ALSO, DAVID, IF HE'S NOT A
CANDIDATE HE'S A FORMER
PRESIDENT BUT ALSO JUST THE GUY
IN MAR-A-LAGO.
AND A LOT OF THE ENERGY AROUND
HIM AND THE SENSE OF BEING IN
THE CENTER OF THE STORM
DISSIPATES AND YOU'RE JUST THE
GUY IN MAR-A-LAGO WHO'S STILL AT
THE CENTER OF A LEGAL STORM BUT
WITHOUT ANY OF THE KIND OF
FUTURE POTENTIAL OUT HERE.
>> WELL, YOU KNOW I AGREE WITH
THAT, BUT DON'T UNDERESTIMATE
THE TRUMP FAN BASE.
THERE ARE A GREAT DEAL OF PEOPLE
WHO ARE NOT GOING TO STOP
FOLLOWING DONALD TRUMP JUST
BECAUSE HE'S A CANDIDATE.
THE NOTION OF THE PRESIDENT --
THE FORMER PRESIDENT IS A KING
MAKER STILL REMAINS VERY STRONG.
BUT IF HE'S